grammar in a language is like a very
small part of learning the language it's
very easy to figure out how the language
works it takes a long time to get enough
words and enough exposure to the
language listening reading speaking
speaking with mistakes so that you
eventually get used to the language so I
was looking through some of my books and
you know I was in Poland polish is meant
to be a difficult language but here is a
grammar book concise polish grammar yeah
small short all you need similarly
essential German grammar that's all you
need or here's a checkbook on Russian
grammar gramatica
fine that's all you need and then I come
across this book understanding and using
English grammar a great big thick book
I've gone through looked up different
things all kinds of exercises a waste of
time if you want to learn languages
forget about mastering the grammar
listen and read